- Smile for Week 15 playoff picture.
- Stop trying to do everything but play football for me.
- NO, GRONK DO MEDIA NOW.
- TAKE OFF THE CAP.
- Oh, cap space? I like that!
- OK, so the coverage is a cap.
- FUN, A NO-LOOK PHOTO.
- OK, fun TBT from last year! BYEEEE.
- COWBOYS IN.
- We’re not presentable for this picture.
- GRONK SAY, UH, EAGLES THEN.
- Yeah, us too.
- Um, we’re from the NFC East. We’re the...Delaware Clams.
- WHERE ARE STEELERS STARS?
- Ah…it’s so quiet.
- If that’s the dumbest thing I have to deal with now, sure.
- Uh, these lights are a little bright for me.
- [Together:] We know.
- HOW IS TANNEHILL STILL AROUND?
- Because I look good now, baby!
- Hey, man, hopefully one day you’ll have as many rings as me.
- LAMAR, MOVE FRONT OF JOSH.
Oh, let me get out of your way, good sir.
- AND FRONT OF TOM.
- WHAT? I'm young. I blame the refs for making me not young.
- AW, THEY TOLD ME THERE WAS GONNA BE A GOAT HERE.
- GRONK HAS LAUNDRY-DETERGENT SPONSORED
RAVE STARTING SOON, SO EVERYBODY SAY, “69.”
- No
- I don’t get it.
- That’s inappropriate.
- What does that mean?
- Sixty-nine.
- BIG TRUSS. POST THAT ON MAIN.
- WOO WOO.
SUBSCRIBE BELOW.
WATCH GRIDIRON HEIGHTS.
JOIN THE GH FLOCK.
DON’T WATCH ANYTHING ELSE.
QUIT SCHOOL.
THIS SHOW IS YOUR LIFE NOW.
GET A GRIDIRON HEIGHTS TATTOO.
WOO WOO.
ANY PROBLEMS? COME SEE ME.